[Music]
let me come back to
the rage for a second because i would
love to get your
advice or at least hear of some of your
learnings over the last decades because
i recall from our first conversation
that
you know in your 40s your successful
doctor
you're driven workaholic you had
challenges in your marriage your kids
were at least based on my notes afraid
of you at points because of your rages
right what have you
learned about rage and anger how do you
relate to it or metabolize it and i ask
as someone who has a long history of
[Music]
running on
anger as a maybe a corrosive fuel of
sorts so i would i would love to just
hear you expand on that in any way that
makes sense
so was a great neuroscientist his name
was yak pancek pank scpp
who tragically died a few years ago of
cancer
and he distinguished a number of brain
systems that we share with other mammals
they include
care he capitalized these so you see a
re care
then something
he caused grief and panic
then fear
lust
seeking
play
and rage
these are all brain systems that we have
they're all necessary for mammalian life
they're all necessary
another by ragey means
the anger that arises when our
boundaries are being transgressed
if i were to
infringe on your boundaries either
physically or emotionally
the
healthy response for you
is to mount an anger response
no get out
stay away
that's healthy
healthy anger is in the moment
it protects your boundaries
and then it's gone
it's not necessary anymore
however
if your boundaries were infringed as a
child
but you could not express it
it doesn't disappear
it gets suppressed
it becomes almost like a volcano that's
gurgling and and bubbling inside you
but it's had no expression
now why did you suppress it because
if you're being
well are you being very public about
this so i'm sure you'll allow me to
mention it but you've
some time after
you and i talked you actually publicly
acknowledged that you'd been sexually
abused as a child
yeah i did
now
when that's happening to a small child
the last thing you can afford is to is
to be
angry because if you get rageful
at the boundary invasion
you're gonna get hurt even more
so suppressing that rage becomes a
survival mechanism
nothing wrong with it it's the right
thing to do
you don't do it your brain will do it
for you automatically as a way of
preserving your life
or your your relative safety
but the race doesn't go away
what happens then later on as an adult
something triggers you and also it just
explodes out of you
and you have no control over it
now it's no longer a response
a healthy response to the present moment
but it's a response to the past and just
as my
hurt and sense of abandonment and enrage
was triggered by my wife not picking me
up at the airport
so a person's rage can be triggered by
something relatively minor
but all of a sudden this
lava flow just explodes out of you
and
the difference between healthy anger
and by the way suppressing healthy anger
is also unhealthy for you we can talk
about that but
just as healthy anger
expresses itself does its job and then
it's gone
rage the way such as i'm describing such
as the way i used to experience it and
probably as used to experience it the
more it explodes the bigger it gets
that's what happens to me it doesn't
pass through me sorry no i was just
reinforcing that by saying you know i've
i've worked with certain therapists
who've said you know punch a pillow
express the rage let it just pass
through you like the wind but that isn't
in fact what happens with me and i know
i'm not the only one it actually
magnifies and intensifies and extends
this feeling
exactly because it recruits more brain
circuits into its service
so that's the difference between
healthy anger on the one hand which is
an essential boundary defense
and by the way so much parenting advice
in this culture tells parents
to force kids to suppress their anger
really unhealthy advice
and
there's healthy anger then there's that
rage that you and i have both
experienced
that
to work with that
no it's
look if you're gonna punch a human being
and there's a pillow to punch instead
better to punch the pillow
right no question about that but there's
a technique of dealing with it no that's
not how you learn to
process that rage because it needs to be
processed
how do you approach
the processing what is a more effective
prescription or one possible way
of thinking about it or approaching it
well if i was working with you
i would encourage you to fully
experience the body experience of rage
what's happening in your body
and you'll find that it's not just an
idea in your head
it's
something that
dominates your visceral experience of
yourself
your muscles your breathing
your abdomen
your entire nervous system
and um there's ways of just helping you
experience it
experience it by
recognizing raising the awareness of of
being with it now that there's a
wonderful buddhist
the lineage spiritual teacher meditation
teacher called tara brach who talks
about rain
recognize
allow
investigate and nurture
so you recognize oh yeah this is
happening to me right now
okay
i'm gonna allow it
not
along it in the sense of i'm gonna act
it out on somebody else
but i want to be with the experience
and then
investigate okay what is this really all
about
and then nurture that little person that
had to suppress all that rage it's a
nutshell
view of it but in other words
there's ways of working with it through
the body
that doesn't involve either suppressing
it or acting it out
but in experiencing it
you